Hiking, camping and exploring the woods
is a favorite past-time for many children
and adults. But you are in for a big
surprise if you happen to stumble
upon THIS particular expanse of woods -
designated by the foundation as: SCP-4000.
It’s an extradimensional area occupied
by the Fae - A powerful race of reality
warpers believed to have been at war with the
Foundation after the infamous Factory incident.
The woods are their domain, but Foundation
operatives must take a path through it
once every year. However they must
abide by certain rules while inside,
like never using or answering to names - your
own or any others - while inside SCP-4000,
as it gives the mystical
entities great power over you.
One researcher, Dr. Japers, made the mistake of
not taking this seriously - After speaking with
a rabbit man, and responding to the name “fellow
scholar” twice in a row, he was owned by the Fae.
He disappeared after returning from SCP-4000, only
to be replaced by a humble, non-anomalous rabbit.